the bill will provide 2.6 billion  dollars for U.S attorneys which would  include funding efforts to the further  support prosecutions related to the  January 6 attack on the capital and  domestic attack  2.6 billion dollars in legal fees Jesus  Christ  I mean am I the only one that reads this  and says what the okay so let's break it  do you know how many how many lawyers  you would have to give 2.6 million  dollars in fees for this let's do the  math okay what's 2.6 billion dollars  divided by say a thousand take say they  found a thousand names that they're  going to do you execute they're going to  be giving a thousand lawyers 2.6 million  dollars thousand that's it a thousand  lawyers are gonna get 2.6 million  dollars what are we talking about and by  the way by the way this is prosecution  not defense defense is What expenses  prosecution you build an indictment you  put it on the table